you've been waiting for this tweet from
someone who you don't know who they are
what they look like hi I'm Alison Brie
I'm Dave Franco and we're at BuzzFeed
and we're about to read some thirst
tweets thirst tweets I feel excited I
feel horny already if if I don't turn
beat Red by the end of this we have
failed
[Music]
so I'm gonna read the ones that are
directed at you and I'll read the ones
directed at you thinking about Allison
Breeze boobs again I I relate that's the
whole tweet that's it think about my
boobs again good boobs be easy to think
about thanks honey early days I remember
my mom this was like when I was on
community my mom was like seems like
everyone on the Internet is excited
about your boobs but I don't know why
they're just okay and look mom in your
face still bored thinking about Dave
Franco's naked booty wow you've shown
some good naked butt I think of
neighbors doing a little Jackrabbit hump
and then I mean they looked great babe
thank you oh Alison Brie sexy and
married to Dave Franco she's literally
winning she's winning so hard and all I
can do is watch
whoa
that should be like my daily affirmation
that I say to myself every morning
Allison Breeze sexy strong start I'd cut
my foot off to see Alison Brie naked
you're in luck
[Applause]
I'd let Dave Franco cut off my fingers
and then eat them I'd let Dave Franco
cut off my fingers and then eat them and
then eat them chop them off get
tourniquet for her and then you just get
a little
be honest do you think Alison Brie and
Dave Franco would consider having a
Joint Sugar Baby because I would like to
join that relationship but also I'm
younger and poorer so we could make it a
thing I'm a little confused
like we're the sugar daddy we're the
sugar daddy to our little baby oh I
guess I've never heard
all caps Alison Brie Mommy hello hi bark
bark woof
we're getting a little too baby mommy
daddy fantalizing but I liked the dog
Barky like the bark bark wolf to close
it out yeah okay I have Dave Franco as
my home screen I almost nut every time I
exit an app whoa
I'm not I didn't realize how how
aggressive the word nut is what a day in
the life of this person oh my god listen
I am bisexual for a reason and that
reason is strictly to be used in a
threesome by Dave Franco and Alison Brie
that's also why I'm bisexual you've been
waiting for this tweet from someone who
you don't know who they are what they
look like
yeah I I it makes sense it checks out
Allison Brie is living breathing wet
dream great I concur oh political
I would let Dave Franco me in front
of the president
whoa exciting it's exciting depends what
president I go current yeah supportive
yeah I feel like we shouldn't go too far
down
Allison Brie mommy choke me
so much Mommy you know people will call
us mom and dad on the internet and I'm
cool with it how do you feel about the
choke me element of that tweet I feel
medium sure oh my God
a woman after my own heart I'd let Dave
Franco
I'd let Dave Franco finger pop my
this is one of my favorite lines
in 2018 yeah meanwhile you guys were
over here finger popping each other's
oh wow beautiful
that's Charming I'd let Allison Brie
chloroform me that's a community
reference oh that was fun I liked
chloroforming that guy why so powerful
yeah Dave Franco is really daddy AF I
want him to curse me out and call me his
while he picks me in the ass for
like four days four days I'm I'm I'm I'm
proud I'm proud of them I actually think
there's a fair amount of restraint for
four days it's a precise drink number
it's a precise number all right
absolutely ashamed of the fact that I
would let Allison Brie rail me into
Oblivion that's all
you're gonna get railed by me if Dave
Franco asked me to lick his anus I would
a lot of ass play going on I will say we
brought it back around to your anus like
the other tweets are more focused on
their own anuses and what you would do
to them and now we're paying some
attention to yours uh I'd let Allison
Brie Chokehold me with her thighs
oh my God
it's for it today I have very strong
Boots the camera
can I how about that Dave Franco is so
hot he could raw me he could raw me
we're learning some news
Allison Brie four commas I'm just a hole
I'm just a hole
depending on how you read it it could
actually be very sweet
again just a hole for me I'm just oh
yeah oh for me oh interesting Dave
Franco please murder my bushy
butt butt
this is why the male the
baby I only know this from Peloton what
do you how do you know it from Peloton
they're on there talking about blissy
like oh I know what it was less
culturistas I don't know how new it is
honey we might just be mommy and daddy
we're going a little bit of a different
direction on this
I would let Allison Brie poop on me
had to end there yeah questions I'm
bummed you're bummed
literally only in the way in which I'm
like thinking about poop coming out of
my bum onto somebody there was 22 of
these I think 19 of them had to do
yes they know we love buttholes in
general thanks BuzzFeed what a blast
very flattered make sure to watch our
film Somebody I Used to Know on Amazon
Prime there's nudity and buttholes are
there buttholes there's two ducks
there's two ducks and I go naked there's
no butthole
[Music]
foreign